Every person wants to go to Mecca at least once in his life and see the
house of Allah and see the Prophet
Sallallahu Alehi Vallam every day. So this was my only
wish and then my even bigger wish was to
go on foot and meet
Allah on foot.  I should see the house of Prophet
Sallallahu Alehi Vallam every day.
This thought did not occur to Kilometer but
because people kept meeting me on the way, they kept
appreciating me due to which
I did not feel the journey as it is and
I traveled with the wonderful Sunny.
Whatever thing was available to me from the [music] person,
like I got a mosque or
got a good post or got a hotel or a
friend made me stay with him, I used to
stay and if nothing happened.
So, I have gone through many things, what is
inside the Sahara, what is inside the tent [
Music]
Alhamdulillah, despite that, I
continued my journey and because of which
I am present here today, so
this is my village.  Whenever you want to do something in life,
you are on yourself, remember everything
and always think positive and
whatever you want to do, do it,
Allah Pak will definitely make you successful.